good how are you alright can I just get
you just sit down real quick I want to
see if I can just to go tonight buy
videos just set up real quick so again
[Music]
we don't she likes it we were told that
a Bloody Mary is
Madeline's one of her go to drinks so
that's what we have set up here I'm
making an itinerary so we can give her a
proper presentation of all the fun that
is to follow
we have streamers we have these really
cute blue lanterns we have balloons
it's Madeline's best day ever poster
we've had these munchkins ready for her
[Music]
all right let's get these pickles baby
you're not supposed to welcome to the
video the video is us giving you the
best day ever this is also very
important is your favorite color blue
yes bloody marys how do we feel
[Music]
it is the next phase of Madeleine day
where we going Madeleine I meant to ask
on a scale of one to ten how shocked
like what was going through your head
[Music]
this was actually worth it did you see
the grow yes
I didn't plan this Madeline I didn't
plan this but we just saw one of the
most prestigious one of the most
decorated actors there is Richard kind a
bing-bong from inside out Alan really
liked Thai food so I was thinking I
could order food from one of my favorite
Thai restaurants called fish cheeks they
have some pretty bomb curry
we have clams we have fried rice we have
two types of curry green curry and crab
coconut curry and we have a salad and
wings and a huge bowl of rice
[Music]
this is the best jingling I've ever had
we don't know be honest I think maybe
after the dog hotel it will like be up
there what is all that top I went to
Australia and study abroad my friend do
you want to talk about what's happening
next
since Madeleine loves dogs we're going
to a dog hotel we're gonna put you in
the center of the hotel and all the dogs
will be around you're gonna be like the
Moses that's taught us just gonna part
the Seas it's gonna be beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why did you stop knitting right
[Music]
best day ever together and forever
cheats my life
I just wanna watch you breathe holding
onto every
more